on sir talk that I've ever done so I
feel like I'm in a weird place but yes
I'm I work at the East Science Institute
which is at University of Washington
just across the lake from here and I
want to tell you a little bit about
about what we're doing there to kind of
to to think about data science within
the context of the University and along
the way I'll get to tell you some fun
things about astronomy and some other
stuff that we have going on so basically
the UW sciences it's a it's a
cross-disciplinary Institute and the
goal is to provide training and support
for modern data intensive research
alright that's kind of a mouthful but
basically we're just trying to support
all the efforts that are happening at
u-dub in this space and recognize that
there are lots of areas of overlap where
we can learn from each other and we were
funded we're lucky to be funded by a lot
of really great organizations the big
one is this one the Alfred P sloan
foundation in the Gordon and Betty Moore
Foundation and this is what really spun
up our efforts starting about a year and
a half ago we got this grant between
udub NYU and UC Berkeley to start these
data science Institute's and explore
what it means to do data science in an
academic context and then we also have
all these these other more local
sponsorships to u-dub that help us to do
what the kinds of things that I'm going
to tell you about but but first before I
kind of launch into these details about
what we're doing since I have you know a
few minutes I thought about I'd talk
about something that's really close to
my heart which is astronomy my
background is astronomy I received my
PhD in astronomy from u-dub and and I
still when I when I have the chance
between all my other duties I like to
work on Astro research and a big part of
my research that that since my PhD that
I've been working on is this thing
called astro statistics which is sort of
a cool conglomeration of different
things and that the idea with a stirrer
statistics is we're trying to take
current methods that are used in
astronomy things that have been used for
the last 10 20 50 or even a hundred
years and it
extend them so that we can use them on
sparse noisy heterogeneous data that we
get out of modern surveys how to scale
these methods up to larger data sets and
then even thinking about development of
new statistical methods that can that
can help us answer these questions so as
an example of this here's a here's a
picture of does anyone recognize what
this is it's that's the Pleiades cluster
so this is a this is a cluster of stars
out there it's called an open cluster
because it's it's not as tightly
gravitationally bound as other clusters
but it's actually a cluster of stars you
look at these up in the sky and if you
put if you put your thumb out it's the
pleat is it is a bit little bigger than
your thumb at arm's length up on the sky
that's what we're looking at here and we
know from studying these that these are
not just projected you know that they're
not just near nearby each other in
projection they're actually nearby each
other in space and this brings up one of
these interesting questions which is how
do we determine the distance the stars
like this and this this distance this
distance question comes up in a lot of
things and in all these different areas
that we're studying right now if you
want to say measure the expansion of the
universe and the Big Bang you have to
you have to figure out the distances to
these galaxies to measure their
recession and how it relates to to the
expansion of the universe learning about
dark matter and dark energy
fundamentally is about getting accurate
distances to these tracers and other
things the spiral structure of the
galaxy down here in the bottom right
corner we know that our galaxy is this
spiral shape and the reason we know that
is because we can look out in this into
the sky and see the distances to all
these stars and map them out and see the
spiral arms like this so but the
question is how do we determine these
distances and does anyone have any ideas
how you like we're looking out at the
sky and all we see is a little point of
light out there so how how do we
determine the distance to a point of
light
up in the sky someone said brightness
yeah you can you could use the
brightness right if you if you know like
that if you know the true brightness and
you know it's apparent brightness you
can figure out how far away it is and
that's 11 really important thing any
other ideas yeah yeah so measuring the
time it takes light if you had a way the
problem is you don't really know when
the lights started traveling right
what's that oh yeah if you could send a
signal so we've actually done that for
nearby planets like can bounce radar
signals or light signals off the moon
and get its its distance very very
accurately but unfortunately with with
stars that are thousands of light-years
away that doesn't work as well yeah
triangulation that's another one and
that's actually kind of one of the more
fundamental ones trying triangulation
and in astronomy we call this
triangulation parallax and the idea is
you know if you if you put your finger
in front of your eye and your blink one
eye and then the other it looks like
your fingers moving against the
background right we do that same thing
with stars except our our baseline that
we're looking at is where we are in the
earth on different sides of the Sun so
in July the star looks like it's on one
side I think I have a laser pointer here
does that work yeah in July right here
the star looks like it's on what in one
location in reference to the background
stars and in January the star looks like
it's in another location in reference to
the background stars so we can actually
do that math and then it's just simple
geometry if we know how far the earth is
from the Sun we can figure out that
angle out to stars and this is great it
works pretty well up until you know a
few hundred maybe a few thousand
light-years the problem is the farther
away that star gets the harder it is to
measure that angle this the angle gets
really small as you move further and
further away all right so then we get to
this other thing that someone back there
mentioned the brightness so we can if we
want to go out farther we can use this
this method of standard candles and the
idea again is that if you know the
intrinsic brightness of a star and you
know it's apparent brightness
just as one over R squared relation and
you can figure out the distance to it so
like if you knew that each of these
streetlights right here was exactly 100
watts and you measured the apparent
brightness from that streetlight way
down at the end of the Avenue you'd be
able to calculate the exact distance to
that street light so we can do that in
astronomy but it turns out it's very
very hard right because you need to know
the exact brightness intrinsic
brightness of an object so now the
question is how do you determine the
exact intrinsic brightness of a point of
light in the sky that you're looking at
and it's it's kind of an interesting
interesting question and there been a
few methods of doing this but one of the
more important in the last hundred years
has been this idea of variable stars so
look at a star in the middle of these
images these are taken several weeks
apart and you can see the stars bright
here and then it kind of gets fainter it
goes away it gets really dim and then it
gets bright again over a period of a few
weeks and these variable stars if you
the interesting thing about this is if
you plot them up you see kind of a
pattern in the variation so this here
we're looking at the brightness on the
y-axis versus time on the x-axis and you
plot these stars and you see that they
get brighter and fainter and brighter
and fainter and people knew about these
for a long time and they were studying
them and there were people who whose
jobs it was to look at these stars and
catalog these observations and kind of
look at these things in detail one of
the more famous names that you'll see in
this in this area is Henrietta Leavitt
and she was she was a computer you know
back in the days before computers were
these digital machines computers were
actually women that were hired by places
like Harvard so she was a computer in
the Astronomy group at Harvard and what
she did with her time was look at these
photographic plates of stars and measure
very precisely the the size of the stars
on the plates and because of the
characteristics of photographic plates
the size of the stars related to its
brightness and she was looking at
repeated observations of these these
variable stars just like this one right
here and found something really
interesting if you look at the at the
period of variation here on the x-axis
and plotted against the distance that
you know from you know from other uh
sorry that you know from you know from
other measurements if you look at that
period in the distance you can see that
there's this relationship between them
there's a linear relationship or slight
almost linear relationship so what she
showed is this fundamental thing that
you have a period luminosity
relationship between between stars sorry
I messed that up I said this is distance
this is actually brightness on the
y-axis so we're looking at the period
versus the brightness and there's a
relationship so what this means is that
if you look out into space if you look
out at a distant galaxy and you find one
of these stars and it has this shape of
variation right here you can from that
infer exactly what its intrinsic
brightness is and from its intrinsic
brightness you can compute the distance
to that star right so this is really
this is an fundamental in 20th century
astronomy this sort of thing and and a
big something that you've probably heard
of is edwin hubble hubble space
telescope was named after him he
discovered using this distance redshift
relationship that the universe was
expanding and you know all of a sudden
in the early 20th century our conception
of the universe entirely changed and we
now have this idea of the big bang and
the expanding universe and things like
dark matter and dark energy and this is
all because henrietta leavitt did the
detailed work of plotting these variable
stars and found this incredible
relationship that enabled all this
science right so where do we come in in
there this is where do we come in after
this that this kind of analysis is
actually going to get a lot harder in
the future and that's because instead of
looking at just 20 little data points
that we can think about and ponder
individually we're looking at millions
and billions of data points right and
pushing these methods these these types
of things like find
periods in in stellar data pushing these
methods into the realm of data that we
have now is is a challenge and that's
where Astro statistics comes in so one
example of where this is going to get
incredibly challenging and incredibly
interesting is this project called the
large synoptic survey telescope this is
a mock-up of the telescope that's being
built right now on a mountaintop in
Chile and the Attic ama desert driest
place on earth just for reference this
is a size of a person in relationship to
the telescope so the telescope has about
an eight and a half meter diameter
mirror it has a one of the largest ccd
cameras ever developed it has I I think
I did the calculation once the the
camera has so many pixels that if you
wanted to view an image where you saw
every pixel in it you'd have to stack
1,500 high-definition TVs and a grid on
the law in order to see every pixel of a
single image and that single image
that's going to be there they're going
to be two of those exposures every 30
seconds and that's going to happen over
the course of ten years every night so
the the data rate is about 30 terabytes
tonight and we end up with a catalog of
hundreds of petabytes of data and from
this data you know it's it's basically
the idea of the LSST telescope is that
in the past if you were an astronomer
wanting to study something you would
apply for telescope time and then point
the telescope there and look at it now
in the Ellises tiara if you're an
astronomer who wants to look at
something you write a sequel query and
then you have the observation on it
right it's turning the sky into the
database and the important thing about
LSST is it's going to scan the entire
sky it has such a large field of view
that it'll scan the entire sky every
three nights so it means that we have a
thousand frames in this whole sky movie
over the course of ten years and it
there's a lot of data in there but this
data is is interesting it's you know
it's it's large but it's also if we're
looking at faint objects there's a lot
of noise in the data and we're also
looking at very heterogeneous data what
it means when you're trying to when
you're trying to create a survey that
solves everybody
problems at once you don't solve any of
those problems exactly perfectly so if I
want to do something like learn about
dark matter in distant galaxies from
LSST the data that comes out of it is
not exactly what I would design for a
for a purpose oriented survey that
suggests for finding Dark Matter so it's
a little bit more difficult to work with
but it serves everyone's needs pretty
well that's what i mean by heterogeneous
so one example of heterogeneous is each
exposure isolates one wavelength range
like you might look at red light versus
blue light versus green light and for
some things like finding variability and
stars that's difficult because you
compare the red light one night to the
green light the next night and all of a
sudden you need a model of the spectral
variability of that star in order to say
if it's varying so things get difficult
and just as an example of I like to show
this because it shows that I still can
do actual scientific work even though I
spend most of my time hacking away at
code this is a paper that we submitted
earlier this year we're basically we
were looking at a new method for
periodic grams of multiband data so
essentially we're looking at we're
looking at this data and trying to
figure out if this is periodic so that
we can figure out what type of start is
and use it as a distance indicator like
I was showing before and with old data
with the types of data that we used to
get from these these purpose oriented
surveys if you look at any single band
here we have the the ultraviolet band
the green band at the red band is the
infrared and the and the far infrared if
you look at any single band you get a
periodic ram with a nice spike that
tells you exactly what that period is so
what this says is that with old-style
data pre LSST data where you have you're
looking at things every night through
every band any single band is good
enough to use the old method and
basically find the period but when you
start looking at the type of data LSST
is going to have you it's not it's not a
purpose oriented survey so you you have
more heterogeneous data you have
you have less fewer observations in each
individual band and you can see here
that the old method doesn't work you
basically lose the periodicity in the
noise and what we propose in this paper
is a way to essentially use all this
data at once and create a multiband
periodic Ram where you recover that
information right there so the cool
thing about this I like to say that
Astro statistics is great because it's
really easy right statisticians would
look at this and say well yeah we knew
how to do that in nineteen sixty but
astronomers don't know how to do this
yet right it's essentially what we did
is we we created a regularized general
linear model for the data and then and
did a few things to pull it out so it's
nothing really really sophisticated but
it's a new application and astronomy
this is something I love about astro
statistics you can you can kind of talk
to your CS colleagues and your stats
colleagues and brainstorm and get some
ideas and you come up with something
they've known forever that you can apply
a new and astronomy and make some
progress that's very cool and the
progress that were made that we're
making here with this is if you compare
the dotted lines which are the old
methods the best of the old methods to
the solid line which is our method you
can see that after five years of LSST
data we're recovering a hundred percent
of these interesting stars that will
help us trace out the structure of the
galaxy whereas the old methods would
have recovered only about fifty percent
or so so it means that with the you know
with simple statistical was simple
progress in statistical methods this
means we can do about twice as much
science in a given amount of time so
this is the kind of stuff that I work on
and a lot of other folks and in Astro
statistics like to work on so the
important features of this i should say
is that it's yeah it's it's simple it's
well-documented if you want the code you
can do pip install gatsby get this is
the best acronym I've ever come up with
in my life by the way this is
generalized generalized tools for
astronomical time series in Python got
Gatsby it's great and
I meant that and code the codes on
github to reproduce the entire paper so
you can basically go and everything from
the latex source to the source of the
figures to the simulations that we did
so this is the kind of thing that's
becoming very important this this
reproducibility and this this putting
your code out there to put the actual
scholarship out there instead of just
the advertisement of it in donohoe's
words and this is the kind of thing that
we're pushing at the Science Institute
so I was talking about astronomy but if
you look at basically every field you're
getting into this this data rich era
where there's this deluge of data right
this is why everyone's talking about big
data and why everyone's talking about
data science because there's data
everywhere our ability to gather it and
store it and process it is improving and
so the East Science Institute was
started in this context and starting to
think about you know how do we encourage
and support good software practices how
do we keep good software engineers in
academia so that we can do the types of
computationally intensive research that
we want to do to learn more about the
universe or about whatever we're
studying and more importantly I think
how do we facilitate interdisciplinary
collaborations so that astronomers can
learn from statisticians and so that
neuroimaging folks can learn from
physicists who can learn from social
scientists and everyone who's working
with data at different scales and then
also we want to be able to train
academics to be good computational
researchers right because most of you if
you've come from an academic background
in scientific research you'll probably
say yeah I learned it all on nights and
weekends by reading books and looking at
web tutorials right the curriculum just
doesn't teach the stuff that were that
we're talking about here at the PI data
conference so UWE science started with
with that goal and it's been it's been a
pretty cool ride I joined in January of
2014 right as the big NYU Berkeley and
you dub things started gearing up and we
kicked off in february2014 with a
university-wide call for research
posters
and we had this was awesome we had 137
posters from 30 departments and this is
mary gates hall at u-dub with all these
faculty members and postdocs and grad
students interacting and talking about
research from all different areas this
is the first time for a lot of people
that they had branched out of their own
Department and their own field to learn
about what other people were doing and
that's that's spun off and we have this
this really broad original core faculty
team I won't name them all that you
probably recognize a few folks here Jeff
Harris behind d3 Carlos gastrin is a
dado founder of dado and lots of other
other great people but the point here is
that it's very broad we're all across
campus right if you take a look at the
departments where these people came from
this is U dub map right here Stadium
down there where the Huskies play and
this is the map of the campus in all
these places where the pis come from and
where the steering committee and the
participants come from so we're really
covering the whole campus and what we
did with these Sciences we started the
center right at the middle right there
that's a sixth floor of the physics
astronomy building we have this data
science center and bill how who's one of
our one of our directors looked at this
and you said well what if we you know
pull that off the map and then we send
it to a graphic artist and we get our
logo so this is the e science logo it's
about connecting the whole the whole
campus and having this hub at the middle
where we can pull people together and
have them learn from each other so I
have a I have about five minutes left or
so of maybe five or ten minutes and in
that time I want to tell you a little
bit about the highlights of what we've
been doing there for the past year and a
half a few things one of the big things
we have is promoting interdisciplinary
careers so I'm I'm kind of one of the
poster children of this the
interdisciplinary career thing and I
feel very lucky to be where I am because
you know I was kind of a struggling
astronomy postdoc trying to figure out
what I was going to do next you know
thinking about industry opportunities
thinking about academic opportunities
and really what I wanted to do was just
contributes tough to psyche
learn but there was nobody who wanted to
pay me for that until II science came
along and basically they said they
provided me a position where I can in my
role for for the majority of my position
I can kind of define what success means
whether that's writing a paper one
quarter or contributing software or
teaching a class or things like that and
there there are several people who are
at UW are working as data scientists and
research scientists who are in that same
kind of role where they can define what
success means for them in within the
context of these science and within you
know reasonable limits you can you can
do that so we also have
interdisciplinary postdocs research
scientists we have faculty members who
are in east science and also another
department we have short and long term
fellows and an example of one of these
people is Mario Urich who's an astronomy
professor I was mentioning the LSST
telescope Mario is the lead I think he's
the principal scientist for data
management or I can never remember which
exactly but he's one of the higher ups
in the LSST project and he's one of
these faculty that was hired half by
astronomy and half by e science and he's
an example of a person who probably
wouldn't have been hired as faculty by
astronomy just on the merits of faculty
by itself but the fact that he was doing
this is this sort of intersection area
working on data science and astronomy
meant he was a really good candidate for
this interdisciplinary position and what
it's done what this hyar is done is it's
made you dub basically the place for
survey astronomy in the next ten years
we have three of the three of the very
very high up people in LSST with Mario
and Djokovic ish and Andy Connolly so
it's a it's a it really really has
helped it's helped you Doug become a
really prominent place in the Astronomy
community another thing we have is it's
pretty cool just data science incubator
program so we're taking our cue from
startup incubators and saying you know
what could we do with the students or
stuck in 10 weeks if we had 10 weeks of
focus time with them so we have we we
put out this call we do this twice a
year now put out this call for people to
come work with a data scientist for ten
weeks for a quarter and they basically
commit to two days sitting in the East
Science Institute in the studio space
and working on their own project but
having kind of a mentor in in one of the
local data scientists and the types of
there are a lot of different projects
that have come through here's one that I
really like this was a project by
Gregoire lerton who's a master's student
working with a beef laxman who some of
you might know he's active in Python and
are and they had this data set about
health records in Kenya and essentially
the data was in about a thousand or
maybe 2000 Excel spreadsheets that were
it was all hand entered by people out in
the field and Kenya or out at various
institutes in Kenya and they had this
this zip file of Excel spreadsheet so it
was sitting on the disk for four or five
years because nobody knew what to do
with it no nobody knew how to work with
this so gregoire worked with dan
halperin who is one of our data
scientists now is at Google and AV
flaxman who's a professor at at the
Institute for Health metrics and they
figured out an automated method to kind
of clean this data to go through it to
organize it and essentially unlocked all
this information that had been sitting
there already it was a 10 week project
and it was actually pretty impactful
grégoire lerton was able to write his
master's thesis on it and there's been
some other other projects based on it
and have learned a lot about what's
going on in health and kenya so this was
a 10 week project where we just matched
him with a data scientist and he went
for it another thing we have going on is
interdisciplinary education so we have a
PhD program with data science tracks we
have data science certificates for
undergrads we're working on expanding
that more and then we have a lot of
formal and informal workshops like
software carpentry and an example of
this is we have this 2014 cohort of PhD
fell
so all these all these six students have
a home department but they applied for
this fellowship and are now the cool
thing about this is we got these six
departments to to agree to let these
students for go half of their core
requirements and their phd program and
instead take things like machine
learning statistics database management
and stuff like that data science skills
that they can then apply and teach folks
in their part in their own department so
it's kind of this cool interdisciplinary
PhD thing we have another highlight is
the the data science studio this kind of
picture in the background it's a pretty
awesome space and we we have a lot that
goes on there all the time it's it's
open space it's where the desks are for
the data scientists we have a lot of
meetings and education things going on
there and the location is pretty awesome
it's the sixth floor of the physics
astronomy building 360 degree view I sit
at my desk and I look out the window and
I see Mount Rainier over the water so
it's it's not too bad and that's really
important because if you want people to
gather together and work together you
have to have a space that they want to
gather in right if you're in a
windowless basement I don't think many
people are going to make the trek across
campus to hang out but the the space
that we have is pretty nice and it's
been it's been successful we've had a
lot of really nice collaborations come
out of the out of people just coming
into to work there and be there and one
thing we have going on this summer that
I want to plug this is pretty cool we we
followed the lead of University of
Chicago has done this program called
data science for social good and we have
16 student interns who are mostly grad
students about three quarters from u-dub
and a number from other places on the
east coast and throughout the US and
they're matched with for nonprofit
groups that are working on these social
good projects that are very data
intensive so these are the names of the
projects it for example I like the open
sidewalk graph for accessible trip
planning this is essentially this is a
project that recognizes recognize that
there's a lot of data out there about
sidewalks and crosswalks and curb ramps
and things like that but it's not in out
there in an accessible way right it's
it's hard for someone who's mobility
impaired to say how do I get from third
and pike to sixth and union the most
safe and effective way so what we've
what we've done with them is we're
working with s dot seattle department of
transportation to get access to all
these data sets and to put it into a
format into kind of an app that people
can use and the goal by the end of the
summer is have an app where someone can
ask for directions from point A to point
B and it will basically tell them how to
get there in a way that that matches
their mobility constraints so it's some
really cool programs going on here and
this is kind of what the data science
studio looks like on a daily basis this
summer which is great we have all these
students working together and meeting
and breaking out in little rooms and
writing on the whiteboards and and
really excited to see what's happening
so anyway that's that's all I have to
say about the UW Science Institute
here's my contact info if you want to
get in touch and ask more and I think we
have just a couple more minutes for
questions Thanks so right now but there
oh yeah
yeah the question is are we going to do
the data science for social good on an
ongoing basis I think at this point it's
a one-time experiment we're halfway
through the summer but if it's
successful and if if it seems like
something that's that's been a good good
use of our effort then we'll definitely
do it again and I would say so far from
five weeks in it it seems really really
awesome and I would I would anticipate
that we're going to push for it again
next summer yeah yeah that's a good
question so the question is for data
scientists working in industry is there
an avenue of collaboration with what we
have going on and the answer is that
that's something we've been thinking
about really hard and we'd like to do
that the concept we have that where we
might experiment with is this idea of an
externship rather than internship you
know if we can if we can get folks from
industry who either get their company to
agree or decide to take a sabbatical to
spend time working with students of you
duh I think that would be a good model
we actually have a couple people from
industry who we've taken leave from
industry and are now working part-time
or full-time as data scientists in the
Institute so that's something if you're
interested in that we should talk
because they're there may be options for
those sorts of things and we're really
interested in making it happen yeah
that's a good question the question
about the key thing we're doing the
foster interdisciplinary collaborations
it's difficult because everybody is at
the University especially is pretty
siloed but we have a kind of
multi-pronged approach we're trying to
we're trying to get students we're
trying to get people young when they're
students through these kind of
interdisciplinary graduate and
undergraduate programs so the PhD
students i mentioned have an advisor in
a data science department like
statistics or computer science applied
math as well as their home department so
we have that we also have a lot of
interdisciplinary seminars and we try to
bring in well-known speakers and do
socials after that and so people end up
end up hanging out and talking we have a
lot of space available where research
groups can come and meet and our
experience has been that professors and
students tend to hang out in the studio
after their research meeting and just
work for a little while the other thing
is the incubator program has been really
big because it's allowed it's allowed us
to make connections between students and
postdocs who are in the incubator with
their research groups and with other
people in the incubator who from
different groups and an example of that
as i worked with someone who was
measuring earthquakes under mount st.
helens and trying to trying to find time
domain characteristics of earthquakes
and it turned out that there was some
literature in astronomy variable star
time series that was relevant to what
they had the problem they were trying to
solve in in geophysics and based on that
we have a postdoc coming in the fall
that is going to be co advised by myself
and John Vitale who's a geophysicist at
u-dub and so then now we have this kind
of this direct Avenue of astronomy and
geophysics in informing this research
and informing each other so it's
happening on and we're experimenting
with how to how to best do it but those
are
ideas yeah one more yeah now the
question is what we're going to do with
social sciences because often
computational methods are not not
recognized we're lucky to have some
really good computational social
scientists at u-dub it's who have been
on the steering committee some faculty
members and so they've been really
driving that and it's actually one of
the one of the explicit things in our
grant between NYU Berkeley and you dub
is to to include fields like social
science and fields like ethnography
learning about learning about data
science itself so we've been lucky in
that sense and and with programs like
this data science for social good it's
also a nice way to get social scientists
into the data seen I guess I think we're
out of time we should probably break for
whatever is next and thanks very much